hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve combination sum
and this is another problem from that
blind 75 list the link will be in the
description so we are doing one more
problem
and have very few problems from this
list remaining
so we're given an array of distinct
integers called
candidates and we're given a target
integer called
target and we just want to return a
list of all the unique combinations of
candidates where all those numbers end
up summing to the
target value and we're allowed to return
those combinations in any order
and we're also allowed to use the same
number from candidates
multiple times but we don't want to have
duplicate
combinations for example if 2 2
3 sums up to 7 right that means
3 2 2 these are the exact same values
right
just in a different order these sum to
seven as well so we don't want to add
both of these combinations to the result
because they're the exact same
so what we're saying is we want
combinations we don't want permutations
that end up summing
to the target value so in this example
you can see
that we are given these candidates and a
target of seven and we have two
different ways that we can sum up to
seven of course seven by itself
does sum up to the target and two
occurrences of the two value and one
occurrence of the three value added
together
are gonna lead to seven as well so then
we return these two combinations
as our result so i would say the
difficult part about this problem is
trying to figure out how to
eliminate duplicate combinations right
for example if we just brute force it
like a decision tree so we have four
different values we can choose we can
choose each of them
an unlimited number of times what we can
do is have four decisions in our
decision tree right like that might be
the naive thing that you start with
so we would get two three
six and seven and then we'd basically
continue that right
on one path over here we would find okay
we found the seven
so we found the target right so we found
one way that we can reach the target
so therefore we don't need to continue
down here because as we add more numbers
all of these values are going to be
positive so as we add more numbers
we're only going to get a sum larger
than the target so you know
i think it's kind of obvious why we
don't continue down this path right
but down here from the six let's try to
continue right we can add a two so we'd
get
six two we could add a three so we get a
six three
we could add another six so we'd get six
six and we could add a seven where we'd
get six seven
so notice how all of these are gonna sum
to a value
greater than the target so down this
path we
never ended up reaching the target we
only went over the target so we don't
continue down any of these paths
right but now let's continue down this
path so here
we'll get we can get another 2 we can
get
a 3 we could get a 2 6 but in that case
we would get 8 which goes over our
target we could also get a 727
but that also goes over our target now
here's the part where we're going to end
up getting duplicates so i'm going to
show you why
this type of decision tree does not work
so here we could get
a 3 for example right so we'd get two
two
three now that sums to the target down
this path we could choose a two so we'd
get two
three two notice how both of these
end up summing to seven but they're the
exact same they're just in a different
order we have two twos and a three
here we also have two twos and a three
so we ended up getting the same
one twice so this works in finding the
combinations but we end up getting
duplicate combinations so what kind of
decision tree can we try
that gets us the result that we want but
does not have these duplicates let me
show you how we're gonna do that
let's logically think about this we know
that we have one value in our
candidates two right so we can try to
get
all combinations that include this
2 value right and see if any of those
combinations leads us to the target
value
7. now we could also so then
if we make a second decision over here
right in this decision we're definitely
including at least
one two now if we go down this path we
want to make sure that
none of the combinations down this path
ever match the combinations down this
path
how can we guarantee that well in this
side we said we're definitely including
at least one two
how about in this side we don't include
even a
single two so basically we skip
two so here we're gonna have an empty
array because we skipped the two right
all we said is we were able to start
from here but we said no we're just not
including a two we're just gonna do
combinations with these three values
that's gonna guarantee that none of the
combinations on both sides are gonna be
matching
and that's basically the logic that
we're gonna follow
so from here remember we can include
multiple twos if we want to right so one
decision here could be including a
second two so we get two two now
this is this path is going to include
all combinations that include
at least two twos right and but remember
our definition for this decision tree
needs to be recursive right because we
don't
want any of the combinations down this
path to be the same as any of the
combinations down this path so what we
said here is
we're going to include two twos how
about down this path
we say that we're we're not including
any more
twos now what we're saying is we had one
two but now we're done we're skipping
twos now we're only going to use values
from here
so that's the recursive thing right
we're basically doing the same decision
down here as we did up here so here
we're going to say we ended up
skipping the two and we're we still only
have one single two
and so let's just continue to repeat
that so over here we're gonna add
another two so we'll have
two two two and over here we'll say okay
we're
now we're done with twos right where
we're gonna keep ourselves at a limit of
two occurrences of two and we're
basically going to continue this logic
until we get to our base case so over
here we're gonna see if we ended up
having four
twos we'll get a target of eight so
therefore we went over
our target value so we're going to stop
but down here right this was up our path
where we said okay we're not going to
include
any more twos in this path so here we
can make a decision we can add a three
so then we'd get two two three so we're
continuing that recursive definition
and so notice how we have two two three
that's seven so we did find at least
one combination but remember down now
for if we make our decision to the right
we wanna make sure we don't have any
duplicates from here so in this
side we decided to add one three how
about down this path we say we're done
adding threes we're not even going to
add a single extra three so
this is going to remain as two two
now i think it's pretty obvious that
down here since we're only allowed to
add values six and seven neither of
these is gonna end up leading to the
target if we add a six
we'll get a total of of ten if we add a
seven we'll get a total of eleven
neither of these
you know both of these go over our
target so let's quickly run through the
rest of the decision tree so over here
over here we said we added a second two
so over here we're not going to be
adding any more to so here we can add a
three so we'd get
two three and over here we would skip
adding threes right so we're gonna we're
not gonna add any more threes this is
gonna remain
as two now down this path at this point
we have a total of five so we're only
allowed to add values three
six or seven all of those are going to
end up leading to
a total of greater than seven so we
can't we won't be able to find any
solutions down this path
i'm just skipping and drawing it out
because we're kind of running out of
room
now over here what we said is we skipped
two
and we and since this path includes the
one where we added a three so here we're
not going to add any threes
and so we're only allowed to choose six
and seven that's going to end up leading
to
uh totals of greater than it's going to
lead to either eight
or nine those are both greater than our
target value
so here we're not allowed to add any
twos because that's what this path was
so we can add a three
or we can choose to skip three
and have add nothing so here since we're
we're not see we're we're skipping three
so we're only allowed to add sixes or
seven so here we can say okay get a six
this path we skip six so we're not
allowed to add any sixes over here
and from over here we'll say okay we can
add a
seven which will give us the total seven
right
that's the target that we're looking for
so we did end up finding that
so that's our second solution that we
found now since this
this path is going to lead to
combinations that do include a seven
this path
cannot include a seven but you notice
how as
we are continuing to go down right paths
what we're saying is okay
we're we're basically removing the
number of elements we can choose from
right we're popping two initially over
here then when we go down here
we're we're not allowing ourselves to
choose three over here we can't choose
six
then when we finally go down all the way
over here we're not even allowed to
choose seven so therefore we have no
choices left so this is also going to be
a base case
because we ran out of elements and the
way we're going to be tracking
which elements we can choose from is
we're going to have a pointer let's call
it i
and so initially it's going to be here
which means we can choose any of these
elements
as we pop an element like this one we'd
end up taking our i pointer and shifting
it over
here which tells us okay we can only
choose these elements now
so that's the main idea this is going to
be a recursion tree each
recursion step we can make two decisions
and it's pretty easy to code up once you
can kind of understand this logic let me
show you how to do that
by the way the time complexity of this
you can see that our decision tree
we're making two decisions each time so
it's going to be 2 to the power
what's the height of our decision tree
going to be well each value in
this is going to be positive it's going
to be at least one so the height of this
decision tree can be at most whatever
the target
value we're trying to make it so t so
two to the power of t
where t is the target value that's going
to be the big o
and uh big o time complexity of this
problem so we are going to do this
recursively but let's have our result
variable which is basically going to be
global for the scope of this problems
because i'm going to define
a depth for search function inside of
our outer function
so a few variables we're going to pass
into here we do want to maintain
which of the candidates we're still
allowed to choose so like i said we're
going to have a pointer i that's going
to determine that
we're also going to have a current
variable we're only going to have a
single occurrence of this it's just
going to be a list that tells us
what values we have added so far to the
current combination for example like we
could have two
we could have two two right two two
three etcetera etcetera
and for the values in our current
combination we do wanna have a total so
we want to be maintaining what's the
total sum of those because if it ever
reaches
our target sum then we know we have
found a solution if we ever go
over our target sum that means we've
reached the base case and we can't
continue anymore
so in our dfs function let's go ahead
and define those base cases we know the
base cases if total ever ends up
reaching target that means we found the
result so what we're going to do is
result dot
append we want to append the actual
combination so we're going to append
current
and we're since we're only maintaining a
single uh
variable list for current we don't want
to actually append current itself we
want to create a copy of it because
we're going to continue to use this
current variable
when we're doing the other combinations
recursively so we don't
because then we're going to be modifying
it so we just want to create a single
copy
before we actually add it to the result
and after we're done with that we don't
want to continue the rest of this
function so we're just going to go ahead
and break out of it by returning
so that's the base case where we succeed
what's the base cases
if we end up uh being impossible to find
a combination well one is going to be if
i is out of bounds meaning we can't
choose any more candidates so if i
is greater than or equal to candidates
or our total ended up going over the
target that we're trying to reach
that's a base case where we have to
return immediately because we cannot
find a combination done
now for the actual recursive step
remember we have two decisions to make
we can choose to include
the value at candidates of i right we
can choose to include this value
what so what are we going to do if we're
including this value well first of all
we're going to take our current
uh values that are in our combination
we're going to take
that candidate and go ahead and append
it to our current
combination right we're going to do that
before we end up actually calling our
dfs function so we're going to call dfs
and what are we going to pass in well
we're including this candidate so we can
potentially
continue to include it right so what
we're going to say for our index i that
we're passing is i stays the same right
we're not restricting which candidates
we're allowed to choose from just yet
so i stays the same we pass in current
because we just updated it right now so
we can go ahead and pass it in
and the total did end up changing so we
took our current total and
added this candidate to it right
so we can go ahead and pass in total
plus candidates of i
so let me delete this line because we're
not doing anything with it
but yeah so this is going to be that
first decision where we do include the
candidate
now the next decision is going to be
where we can't include it
but but after we call this function we
want to clean up a little bit we ended
up adding
uh this value to our current candidates
our current combination so we want to go
ahead and pop that before we go down the
other decision
and bef so once we pop that we can go
down the other decision that's if we're
not
ever going to include this candidate so
for the index we're going to pass an i
plus 1
indicating that we can't include any any
occurrences of i and for current we can
just go ahead and pass in
our current combination and total is
going to stay the same because we didn't
end up adding any value to it right we
we
left our current uh combination as the
same as it was before when we actually
called this function
and once that's done we've we basically
made our two decisions right can you see
what's going on can you see that we
called that for search
once and then we called it a second time
so we did create that two branch
decision
and after we're done with that we can go
ahead and return and in this case we
actually don't need to return
so that is the entire dfs function last
but not least
what we want to do is actually call it
out here so we're going to call it
passing in 0 as the beginning index
passing in an empty array as the current
combination
and passing in 0 as the current total
and then once that is done
we will have updated our result which we
declared up here
and then we can simply go ahead and
return that result it should contain
all the combinations that end up
totaling to the target
so you can see this problem isn't too
bad to code this backtracking approach
isn't too bad once you kind of
understand the two decisions that we're
actually making
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching